[Musique]
antoine veut faire laver sa nouvelle
auto sport dans la boîte à gants il
trouve un vieux coupons pour un lavage
d'auto dont il ne s'est pas servi il
fait là la station-service composent le
code mais la porte du lave-auto reste
fermé l'employé lui fait remarquer qu'il
ya une date sur le coupon est qu'elle
est dépassée en ontario au
nouveau-brunswick et en alberta par
exemple ce coupon serait effectivement
expiré mais au québec
les coupons de lave autos sont
considérés comme des cartes prépayées
s'ils ont une date d'expiration et qui
est passé on doit vous donner un nouveau
coupon et malgré cela ce ne sont pas
tous les lave auto qui acceptent encore
aujourd'hui de se plier à cette loi 100
% québécoise que peut faire en douane
il peut demander à l'employé de la
station service de le remplacer par un
autre
il peut porter plainte à l'opc il peut
décider quel avenir
il ira ailleurs le fin mot de l'histoire
au québec un coupon pour laver votre
bolide est toujours valide